Thank You Kaylee Bernadette and Alexis
for your moving and important words good
afternoon
seniors families and friends my name is
Jackie Schechter and I'm honored to
represent Dunster house on the senior
class committee I have the pleasure of
introducing today's female ivy orator
taylor k phillips taylor k and i in that
freshman year when we live two floors
apart in Weld since then taylor K has
found a new home in Kirkland house and
completed her English concentration and
Dramatic Arts secondary she has served
as a president of the improv troupe on
thin ice and performed in numerous
theatrical productions
she has also honed her love for red
spice chicken and Tina Fey this summer
Taylor K and her sister Tess will be
performing a chi woman comedy show in
her hometown of Kansas City Missouri
then she'll move to New York where by
day she will work as a creative
strategist for a marketing company by
night she'll pursue a future career in
comedy
Taylor K would like to thank her parents
and her sister for their love and
support
please join me in welcoming Taylor K
Phillips our 2015 female IV orator
Thank You class officers faculty and
friends for having me today
it truly is an honor to speak to some of
you and a privilege to make the rest of
you feel inferior to me for the next
seven and a half minutes for I stand
before you today having truly beaten the
odds I have walked the hallowed halls of
Harvard and come out the other side with
two things they told me I could never
have at the same time an English degree
and a job I stand here a shining beacon
of hope for the next generation of young
girls sitting at home right now rudely
correcting someone's grammar and to them
I say you're right little Susie it is
whom but today is not about me and my
job graduation is about something bigger
than us in the next few days we'll get
to hear from a number of distinguished
Harvard alumni like today's incredible
speaker actress Natalie Portman and
tomorrow's speaker who is also great
but graduation is also a time of
reflection and I had a lot of questions
coming into today about me about our
class who are we where are we going what
is guru and to find my answers I did
exactly what my four years of a Harvard
education taught me I googled it at the
last minute and found enough very
specific things to get me participation
points when we leave Harvard according
to Wikipedia and XXIV mom two three
eight on college confidential we believe
the Harvard class of 2015 and join a new
group called the Millennials the comp is
super simple you literally just have to
be born between 1983 and 2002 so it's
like almost as easy as writing an op-ed
for the Crimson
but but guys some of the facts I learned
about Millennials I feel it my duty to
impart to you since 2015 is actually the
year in which the millennial generation
is poised to overtake the baby boomer
generation both in terms of numbers of
people in the workforce and an actual
physical force the baby boomers are very
old but we're not beating the previous
generations at everything for instance
only 26 percent of Millennials right now
are married and I just want to throw out
there that I am available I have an
almost spotless medical history and a
degree in Dramatic Arts to fall back on
if the English thing doesn't work out so
if anyone would like to beat those odds
not anyone mostly anyone who's going to
work at Bain or who shares a name with a
Harvard building or Dean prana
I also learned that we are staying at
our jobs for less time 58% of
Millennials will leave their jobs after
3 years and this one stuck out to me
because I have a job but also because it
speaks to I think a type of constant
creative restlessness among us or maybe
they just fire you after 3 years if you
keep showing up 7 minutes late to
everything
but all of this moving around between
things can also be really exciting look
at our speaker today Natalie Portman she
left Harvard and has changed tons of
things playing and Belen and Padme and
soon Jacqueline Kennedy and as a woman I
think it's really inspiring to know that
I can also leave Harvard and have so
many opportunities to be a powerful
person's wife
changing vocations isn't as easy or fun
as making a joke about the quad in your
class day speech guys it's so far but
seriously four out of every ten
Millennials does not have a job and to
those unemployed in the class of 2015 I
say look to the person on your left look
to the person on your right if you had
to take too long to decide which
direction was which that's probably why
you're unemployable but hey Millennials
are doing great things too seventy-five
percent of Millennials have made a
financial donation to a not-for-profit
institution money to UNICEF for vaccines
or to the Human Rights Campaign for
legislative fees or to our favorite
nonprofit Harvard University force why
more good news 47% of us are tolerant of
other races and other groups forty-seven
percent that is almost half
and our cultural horizons are expanding
to 13% of the millennial generation has
seen a drag show and thanks to Harvard's
Hasty Pudding theatricals 50% of Harvard
students can audition to be in one
also just as a public service
announcement statistics also show that
we as a generation are more trusting
than our predecessors um so I just I
have to tell you guys
there is no $10 Amazon gift card you
just filled out a survey you weren't
entered in anything the fact is we're
all going into a world of big data that
sometimes thinks it knows us better than
we know ourselves but we know the
percentage game better than anyone
because before we start counting
ourselves among the 61 percent of
Millennials who feel their personal
responsibility to help the world or the
39 percent who apparently are just like
nah
let's not forget that only four years
ago we sat out here as the story of 6.2%
and a blue and we all swelled with pride
despite the fact that and I did the math
on this I am and each of you are point
zero six percent of the graduating class
of 2015
you are not even a four percent but when
I got that email when I cried with my
parents and gave my little sister and
inferiority complex that sent her to
therapy on IV day hey Tess hey on IV Day
2011 I felt like a whole percent hey I
felt like forty nine percent and I know
what 49 percent feels like I got one on
the neck ten midterm ones
forty-nine percent it's my first college
B
the truth is in the grand scheme of
things we eat y'all make up like point
zero zero zero zero four percent of the
millennial generation but one of those
point zero zero zero zero four percent
was the first person to say hi to me on
campus one of them cast me in my first
big musical three of them are the full
commits department two two of those
point zero zero zero zero four percent
have been to every single show I have
ever been in on this campus 100 percent
one of you point zero zero zero zero
four percent actually left your jacket
in my room and I'm mostly packed up and
I'm just gonna send a picture to that
list and if it's not yours just reply
all no so as we all go out into the
world probably
according to statistics on married
living with our parents trusting
philanthropic barely employed and racist
let's not forget let's not forget Mark
Twain once said that someone else once
said that there are three types of lies
lies damned lies and statistics because
the Internet doesn't know all of these
things about us because it cares it
knows because Millennials have over a
trillion dollars worth of purchasing
power and they're trying to get us to
buy things and even though it may be
tempting to use these numbers to further
stratify ourselves and compare our
successes to those of our peers inside
and outside of Harvard let's be that
however many percent that resist in our
quest to beat the odds let's not forget
to stay on except you Javed tour guides
y'all need to stop
thank you class of 2015 for a wonderful
18% of my life congratulations and for
the 74% of you that are still single my
number is eight one six seven four four
zero one eight eight when you get
something eight one six seven four four
zero one eight eight thank you